the one-year survival rate for stage 4
pancreatic cancer patients is 18% I'm
very happy to report I have just reached
that marker Alex Trebek revealing that
he's defied the odds one year after
announcing he was diagnosed with stage 4
pancreatic cancer the Jeopardy host
posted his health update to social media
Wednesday morning now I'd be lying if I
said the journey had been an easy one
there were some good days but a lot of
not so good days I joked with friends
that the cancer won't kill me the chemo
treatments will in his nearly two minute
long video message to fans Alex doesn't
sugarcoat his struggles there were
moments of great pain days when certain
bodily functions no longer functioned
and sudden massive attacks of great
depression that made me wonder if it
really was worth fighting on but I
brushed that aside quickly because that
would have been a massive betrayal the
79 year old also paid tribute to the
people who he says helped him find the
strength to persevere my wife and soul
made Jean who has given her all to help
me survive other cancer patients who
have looked to me as an inspiration and
a cheerleader of sorts of the value of
living and hope and it would certainly
have been a betrayal of my faith in God
and the millions of prayers that have
been said on my behalf
according to Trebek's oncologist the
two-year survival rate is only 7 percent
but both he and Trebek are optimistic if
we take it just one day at a time
with a positive attitude anything is
possible
I'll keep you posted the longtime TV
personality has been honest about the
ups and downs of his cancer journey
since announcing his diagnosis last
March this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
and I'm gonna keep working and with the
love and support of my family and
friends and with the health of your
prayers also how are you feeling how's
everything going little tired no time I
taped the show and then I made it to the
dressing room on one location just
barely before I arrived in pain and
cried in pain but he's been adamant
about continuing his hosting duties
[Applause]
it wouldn't be right for me to walk away
from this if I can possibly do it and
his positive attitude has never wavered
neither has his love for his fans what
does all that support mean to you it's
blowing me away I told somebody the
other day that most of us in our
lifetimes never get to know the impact
we've had on other people
you only hear about it after the person
passes away and to be able to experience
it while you're alive is very special
and when it comes to Trebek's legacy he
told ET at the 2019 Daytime Emmys that
he'd like to be remembered this way just
as a good guy a nice man and somebody
that you looked at on television on a
daily basis and said hey you know what I
like him I plan to beat the low survival
rate statistics for this disease so help
me keep the faith and we'll win we'll
get it done thank you
[Music]